a lot of guys
you know we look at those the worst
stories out there the guys who've been
through the most been through the
hardest things you know guys having you
know gone through physical abuse you
know emotional abuse um sexual abuse and
times right guys who grew up in really
shitty situations and it's easy to look
at the guys like that and say wow like
that man had it so hard like i'm so
impressed by how far he's come and those
are heroic stories don't get me wrong
but i think that as men we also tend to
minimize we've been through
it's very easy to to miss all the small
things that beat us down day after day
because in the end of the day like death
by a thousand cuts is still death
right
and there's a lot of guys who will say
oh well my life wasn't as hard as this
person's was like nobody's beating me
when i was a kid obviously there's
nothing wrong with me
you know and they minimize what they
have been through
until they start looking around and
start digging into it and realizing how
bad things really were and how much of
an impact it's really had on us
like that's one thing that i think gets
missed a lot in this space is that
everybody's coming here because there's
something wrong that they can't figure
out they're looking for answers they're
looking to improve they're looking for a
way up out of the darkness that they're
in they're looking for solutions they're
looking for solutions yeah exactly
exactly and it doesn't matter how you
got in that dark place it doesn't matter
why things aren't working out for you or
what it is it's not working out for you
it's not working out for a reason
you shouldn't beat yourself up because
somebody else has it worse you shouldn't
minimize the fact that you're in the
horse in that bad place that you're in
right now you shouldn't minimize the
fact that you're in the darkness like
you're you're there whether however you
got there no matter how hard somebody
else's story was compared to yours
doesn't matter you're there
but the point the second thing they're
right my grandfather used to say all the
time you say uh doesn't matter how
how shitty your life is or how bad you
think things are going there's always
somebody out there that's got it worse
and they and they'd love to trade their
life for yours exactly exactly and if
you sit there you keep comparing
yourself to people who had it worse and
saying oh well mine's not that bad
you're gonna ignore how bad things are
for you
i've seen a lot of guys deal with
for way too long that they shouldn't
because it's not as bad as somebody
else's turn up your volume a little bit
um ryan a little low on the
i should probably add though ryan not to
interrupt you but what identifies us as
men is not
what we have been through and what kind
of victims that we are it's how you
overcome those adversities that makes
you who you are
right
that's 100 true um but every guy is on
his own journey and i think that one
thing that that happens a lot is we say
our my life wasn't as bad as that person
so my life isn't that bad and we're
ignoring exactly how how bad jesus got
right you kind of have to be able to own
that you are in a bad place even if you
didn't go through the worst of the worst
to get there
i agree i mean yeah
you do have to analyze what has come
past and have compassion on yourself
but in the end of the day everybody has
a sob story and we can both be right at
the same time everybody has a soft story
what i want to hear is your story of a
redemption and triumphant
yeah i am ryan if if i could jump in
there i think you kind of at that point
kind of hit home with me because moff
and the rest of the guys will testify i
my origin story i sat in front of
everybody and i said no i'm cool my
life's been great and i think relative
to a lot of the guys there
yeah it has but looking back now and
just subconsciously after going through
stuff what ryan said i was using eating
and drinking as a crotch for five years
straight
and i was i was drinking too much and i
was eating too much and as i said
you know i'm 20 lighter than i was two
years ago and that's because
i finally was able to get pleasure out
of life and not pleasure from calories
and alcohol
so thanks ryan yeah you're welcome well
and like my life hasn't been bad like
nobody was beating me as a kid nothing
like that i grew up in a fairly
middle-class midwest white boy kind of
home and yet i was a complete complete
mess up until last year
you know i was like
near that near that permanent solution
for years and years and years i hadn't
really recognized it and really thought
i was that close but yeah that's where i
was at and it took going through some
serious uh events last year and doing
some heavy work and doing some plant
medicine doing things like that before
that finally came to light to where i
could actually deal with it because i
didn't think that my life was that bad
you know i'm sitting here making six
figures dating women half my age my life
should be good but it wasn't compared to
where i should be and it wasn't compared
to
you know it wasn't nearly as good as it
should have been
are you guys all familiar with uh joseph
campbell and the hero's journey yes oh
yeah extremely have you guys seen
finding joe
no no i have not there's um there's a
video that kind of distills you know the
entire concept down into like a hour
like hour and 20 minute long uh film
um
those of you that are watching it right
now it's probably worth grabbing it you
can
i think you can either download it or
rent it on a certain site just search
for finding joe
um if you're not familiar with it but
basically the hero's journey is just
like storyline arc and it's like you
know it's it's basically the same story
that's used for every hollywood
superhero movie like superman's got
kryptonite uh you know so and so has got
his arch nemesis sort of thing
it's essentially the same storyline and
it it's it's out there that much because
it works right it's because it it really
resonates with peer people and it's a
story that's been told for
hundreds uh thousands of years even um
it's a book
it's a bookie world called the thousand
faces of the hero
yeah she dates back to siddhartha uh the
buddha the story of jesus and also
various uh mayan and indian fairy tales
as as well as disney fairy tales what
all these heroes happen to have in
common there's all yeah like you can
even go back to disney stuff and you can
find that um hero's journey and
sometimes star wars for that matter star
wars skywalker yeah hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you